my two favorite questions to ask in
business and in life are what problem
are we solving and let's play it out
it's like taking the next three to five
moves I quit my job then what happened
let's play it out like what actually
happened because people were like I'm
gonna be homeless that's probably not
realistic play it out you're not going
to spend the same amount of money if you
don't have the income okay well what do
you think you would actually live on
this okay if I actually ran out of money
what would I do well I'd probably call
my parents up and I probably see them on
the couch okay what pain would I
experience in doing that I'd probably
have to be under their rules which would
blow there are pains and then the
question is if these are the costs that
are a short-term cost in order to avoid
the long-term consequence of this
continued zombie existence where I do
not want to be here is that a price I'm
willing to pay